la chose la plus sûre à faire est de suivre un nouveau
parcours de sauvegarde en ligne des poids vifs le
voyage de retour là-bas, ils sortent des cigares
sur vous maintenant sans l'esprit qu'ils ont
réellement donné et les conditions dans lesquelles nous
avons traversé ce film auraient pu être
impossibles
nous avons des fenêtres  d'une heure et demie
pour tourner des scènes très complexes avec des
centaines de figurants donc c'était comme une
pièce de théâtre et tous les acteurs adoptent
cette technique nouvelle c'est un de ces
acteurs que l'on peut
tout comprendre de ses yeux car il y
a très peu de mots qui  il livre il doit
vous faire ressentir de très nombreuses
émotions complexes simultanément avec son
langage corporel et uniquement avec ses yeux comme
il l'a fait c'était pour moi en tant que réalisateur
une incroyable première expérience dans
ma vie
palpable la tension et l'intensité
qui  il apporte à Dieu Tom Hardy J'ai
été un fan incroyable de son travail Je
pense qu'il est l'un des acteurs les plus dynamiques
et son engagement à
créer un personnage est incroyablement
ex  citant pour regarder, je pense que c'est l'un
des travaux les plus brillants qu'il ait jamais
réalisés. Gleeson acteur fantastique
parfait pour le rôle que vous faites
tout seul au bord du ruisseau
Poulter est un acteur tellement rigoureux c'est
très sérieux il est très intense
je me sens  assez privilégié d'avoir vu la
transformation du pays de Galles au cours du
film,
tous les acteurs étaient extrêmement puissants
et je ne pourrais pas être plus heureux de voir
qu'ils sont vraiment le miracle de l'art et de la
transformation.